I mean I've had so many I wish I knew
who told me about you I wish I could
remember it might have been Tom Tom yeah
Tom probably was Tom he was pretty it
was a comic pretty sure as a comic it
might have been Tom he was the first one
to repost one of mine I think maybe
that's what it was I did this show well
I have so many disasters still where I
thought I was like get ready for the
rocket ship Kyle better go mansion
shopping because things are about to
take off and just always something I did
this Jamie Foxx like sketch show pilot
and it like to get a part on a you know
Network show it's a lot of auditions
it's you climb a mountain to get the
role and I was like feeling like this is
my last shot and everything and I got
there and we couldn't we weren't allowed
to write for ourselves what is a WGA
rules or something and you know you have
a character no one else can really write
for it and the people that were writing
to of them just got out of prison and
they were not comedy writers like Jamie
Foxx is a huge career here I'm really I
think he just was like let me give my
friends this cuz I got all this other
stuff he just didn't give a [ __ ] I need
it no you would show up like once a week
no yeah really
yeah he's busy and you'd come in he come
in with glasses like Shay and we
couldn't we'd read the script and
there'd be no ending or seemingly point
and then one time he threw the script in
the air was like [ __ ] that script do you
you do you you know when he walked out
and the executives like no you can't do
you it was like that it's like he climb
this mountain there's an Arby's at the
top just like oh yeah who's gonna be
these writers called me into their
office once and they were like you know
we had this idea for it these these guys
who never wrote sketch before and their
look is I did like you're you're Jimmy
bond James Bond
you're Jimmy bond all right and you're
you're in an airplane right and like to
take it take it and the next day I'd be
like yeah and you order like a soda like
a like a coca-cola or a sprite or like a
any point that I gotta go Mountain Dew
that Mountain Dew or dico I'm like
uh-huh
that was it the night I just was sitting
there dead silence
what and then we had like this show
which came out very media was a sketch
it was it called it was called in to
flow it got changed to like something
else and it just became like it was a
fee on Crockett's show I was like a hot
like a cast member or whatever and then
at the end you know Fox pays all this
millions of dollars and avions going all
Fox cares about their wallets but we
showed them not realizing we had to wait
for a pickup and I'm just standing on
stage thinking this is my last shot to
have anything cuz I was already like 40
and I just was like let me go to the
wrap party and the whole thing was just
okay so we just were like what's
happening and we go late to the wrap
party and we walk in this nice
restaurant and Jamie Foxx is standing up
and into the whole big table and he's
going down what's your favorite animal
what's your favorite animal it was like
goose I mean a rabbit like what's your
second favorite animal what's your
second baby cuz the first animals who
you think you are
the second animals who you really are I
told Tom Cruise that and he said it was
awesome Instagram yeah I'm gonna write a
book one day just called humiliated a
long career of ground balls I've had so
many like what I really was going
shopping for houses it had to stop
really except for like I had this Pizza
Hut campaign which was like get ready to
like open up several bank accounts and
it was like the big New York of Pizza
yeah you know there's an explosion of
flavors as a shooting nine oh there's a
campaign of videos 9/11 happened
as we're shooting the explosion and it
looked like it was just the wrong vibe
to decay New York a big explosion of
flavors this whole thing so they
canceled the whole thing they played
like I don't know if like a month they
played a few and then they like dropped
it but he was like you know it was I
shop for I got paid like pretty low but
but we're gonna do six more it was gonna
be like one of those flow from you guys
I was a hot guy of Subway yeah for pizza